To reach European sports is as far away from realistic at the moment.
So we don't have this.
Maybe dreaming for fans is always allowed.
For us, it's important that we are very clear how good we are.
We have shown that we can compete against also the best teams in the league.
This is a very good signal, but the tough games are also against the teams.
They are, maybe, on the bottom part of the table,...
...but we have shown in the past that we can also win these games.
They are super tough to win and we see that also other teams are struggling.
Winning games in the Premier League is always super tough,...
...but we have managed it in the past and I think this is also good to see.
But yeah, we will have to look how often we can reach this level...
...and how often we perform at the highest level.
If we do it very often, then we take points and points and points...
...and then we'll see where we end up at the end of the season.
This is the way we want to go.
There are so many good, young, talented players out there,...
...and they should know that there is a very good spot...
...to get your first Premier League experiences.
And I think, meanwhile, we have this image back,...
...and I think this is a good image to have as a club.
Kyle had little problems with his hamstring.
That's also the reason why we subbed him from yesterday's game; that's it so far.
But obviously, we have problems with Sali and with Moi:...
...Moi with his heel and Sali with his, also hamstring, I think.
That's the reason why they weren't available yesterday.
So a few lads with a few issues,...
...but we will have a look at how far they are for the weekend...
...and if they are available, we will see.